[музика]
а що
зробиш А ти дуже любиш ркиня дуже любиш
рки Дай мені
спокій щоразу грають так ніби в останнє
адже чи відбудеться наступна вистава тут
в Одеському українському театрі імені
Василя Василька точно ніхто не знає нині
близько третини творчого складу на
фронті рік воював на херсонському та
Запорізькому напрям і знову опинився в
стінах рідного театру Роман федосєв
вступив до лавзсу в перші дні нападу
Росії на Україну с початку служив
гранатометником а згодом став старшим
бойовим Медиком роти пережив поранення і
контузії а після них тривале лікування і
ось тепер Роман готується до повернення
на сцену мене звільнили в запас і я
повернувся в рідний театр тому що це моя
професія Яя професія актор та режисер
військовий я був під час тоді коли був в
ЗСУ І зараз я ввожусь на одну виставу
Карпатський вестран я буду грати Василя
це одна з провідних ролей цієї вистави
там Ну багато тексту багато рухів із
головною роллю впоратися нелегко адже
нині Роман відновлюється після поранень
і контузій так у мене є декілька На жаль
поранень у мене
там з Коліном і дві дуже такі сильні
контузії я лежав в шпиталі
зараз проходжу лікуюсь реабілітація і ну
втратив там багато слуху Ну я так не
дуже гарно чую все заважає вам це зараз
працювати чи ні Ну звичайно заважає
кожна
кожна болячка заважає кожна болячка
заважає тим більше де я побував там Ну я
на це не не скаржусь там хлопцям ще
гірше досталось і зараз достається це
все що тут відбувається це завдяки нашим
побратимам які зараз боронять нашу
державу поверненню в театр Роман небик
зрадів бо сцену вважає найкращими ліками
Утім не менше зраділи і в самому театрі
адже через брак акторів чоловіків уже
довелося скасувати не одну виставу а
тутешні реалії такі чим довше спектакль
не грають тим складніше його згодом
повернути в репертуар останні півтори
місяці були дуже і дуже складни то
забрали нашого актора і майже полетів
весь репертуар є вистави яки ми ніколи
більше вже не зіграємо наприклад Мені
дуже шкода Але така чудова вистава як
соручинський ярмарок минуло забагато
часу
і купа людей помінялася
робити води до ц до цієї вистави це
шалений час ще і декілька і вистав Ну
вони Загублені і ми не зможемо
повернутися Ну наприклад те що було до
війни ми не повернемося до частини цих
вистав Ну золотетеля ми не зможемо
зіграти тому що там Ну там просто
кількість людей яка пішла з театру
замінити їх просто неможливо і коли
третину творчого складу мобілізовано то
під загрозою не лише окремі вистави а й
робота самого театру тож Юлія пивоварова
намагається домогтися бронювання для
військовозобов'язаних працівників мова
не йде про те що актори не мають воювати
мають воювати ми всі сьогодні розуміємо
Що найголовніше що зараз з нами зі всіми
відбувається це війна але нам теж треба
розуміти що є і необхідність все ж таки
зберіганні українського театру в Одесі
мова йде про те що це має бути якимось
чином врегульовано що ми маємо якимось
чином планувати Що ми робимо що має бути
все ж таки яка хоча б невелика кількість
заброньованих акторів для того і не лише
акторів а і монтувальників і світловиків
і звукачів с початку повномасштабного
вторгнення Росії бронювання для акторів
отримали лише театри які мають статус
національних їх в Україні вісім а всі
інші стикнулися з проблемою мобілізації
Утім саме в Одесі мобілізація театралів
набрала таких обертів що під загрозою
опинилося існування цілого театру
загалом в регіоні неодноразово фіксували
резонансні випадки вручення повісток
дісталося і працівникам театру імені
Василька розповідає директорка за її
словами заслуженого актора України Павла
чирву забрали до військомату просто з
вулиці Він пішов роздрукувати слова йшов
на репетицію біря нового ринку до нього
підійшли заштовхали його до бусика у
людини не було з собою Ані гроші Ані
жодного документа в нього не було нічого
з собою його заштовхали до бусика він
встиг
Зателефонувати головному режисеру до
нашого театру Олександру самусенку до
якого він йшов на репетицію що вибач я
на петицію не не прийду тому що мене
везуть у віськумат далі з ним зник
зв'язок далі я по своїх каналах шукала
де він знаходиться далі ввечері його
сидили х одразу вивезли за місто а
ніякої медичної Комісії не було Це було
відбувалося все взагалі в неділю Ну як
це може бути відтоді актор Павло чирва
на фронті Крім нього на різних напрямках
боронять Україну Ще 16 працівників
театру близько половини з них
мобілізувалися добровільно Ми чекаємо на
пацанів і вони відповідно повернуться
і будемо працювати далі е-а але на той
момент вже коли вони вступили до війська
ее Це був
такий удар для театру попри проблеми з
кадрами та регулярні ракетні удари РФ по
Одесі театр продовжує творити і
працювати крім того каже головний
режисер одесити почали частіше
відвідувати вистави і цьому дуже
тішаться в театрі який багато років
поспіль залишався в тіні російськомовних
театрів міста коли в нас було все не так
однозначно і ми всі е навіть були в
таких досить дружніх стосунках
з тварюками які зараз на нас
напали навіть в той момент ми грали
українською і ніколи не переходили на
російську мову і відповідно Це був такий
осередок української культури Ми їздили
в нас були гастролі Ми їздили в область
е були різні вистави ми возили класичні
українські вистави і дивилось і
молдавське Село і гагауське село Ну що
це як Не робота
з по
українізації російськомовного регіону і
тепер головне завдання колективу
зберегти театр тож Уже понад півроку
директорка оббиває пороги усіх можливих
інстанцій аби домогтися бронювання для
військовозобов'язаних працівників ми
зверталися і до Міністерства культури ми
зверталися до генерально штабу ми
зверталися до Міністерства оборони тому
що Ну ми ж розуміємо що на місцевому
рівні вирішити це питання неможливо
просто неможливо або там Ти йдеш десь
домовляєшся ну ну це неправильно якщо ми
все ж таки живемо яко в якойсь
нормальній країні це має все відбуватися
за законом втім у міністерстві культури
на запит ДВ відповіли займаються тільки
питаннями закладів культури які носять
статус національних а Одеський
український театр імені Василька такого
статусу не має тож нині доля акторів
театру в руках Генерального штабу 13
жовтня Юлія пивоварова надіслала усі
необхідні документи до генштабу Вони й
досі на розгляді тім у театрі кажуть
яким би не було рішення стати на захист
України готові але просять про єдине
збереження театру Мені не страшно піти
вступити до війська але мені страшно що
мені не буде куди повернутися ну тобто
бахмута вже немає тобто повернутися
додому я не зможу мені як людині яка
дуже любить Цей театр
мені навіть Важко уявити що мені потім
не буде куди повернутися актор для цього
театру - це сенс існування якщо забираєш
сенс існування людина може померти Якщо
забрати сенс існування у театру забрати
актора він загине його не
[музика]
буде
критю